in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jamie
and Lara are with us hey guys how are
you tonight
welcome welcome where do y'all live we
live in Lima it's just outside of
Boulder Colorado oh very cool welcome to
Nashville and here to do a debt-free
screen absolutely I love it how much
have you paid off paid off sixty one
thousand dollars in 18 months
way to go and income range during that
time we started off between the two of
us making about $80,000 and right now
we're making about 85 very good very
cool good for you
so what kind of debt was the sixty one
thousand dollars well go for it it was a
credit card and a car loan and student
loans and what was the big portion of
the student loans how much of it was
that $40,000 okay so 40 of the 60 was
that and so some credit miscellaneous
credit card miscellaneous car all right
and so you were normal regular folk life
is be bopping along in fact we're making
all the money and all the money goes
back out the door yeah that's that's
future Jaime's problem yeah we'll do a
future Jamie later
yeah and 18 months ago what happened so
this actually started for me back in
2008 my mom got me total money makeover
for Christmas and read through it was
like this makes so much sense
so in January 2009 I started on my first
budget that was actually when we started
dating and we had a few philosophical
conversations about money like a debt
freedom is great and that's eventually
where we want to go but we never got
into any detail until when we got
married in July of 2014
oh and that's that's not all that was
that's what you know I've been dating
budget girl and it was cute but now I
married the budget girl well yeah and I
know what what happened Ava's we sat
down we made our had our first budget
committee meeting and the number at the
bottom of the spreadsheet was read oh
and right then I was like we're doing
this we're going oh we're going now so
you don't have to use your budget girl
powers on
no fun very cool because she's but
you've been working this you were gay
yeah how much debt did you have did you
bring into the marriage so I was
debt-free I had at one point borrowed a
few hundred dollars from my parents and
that was the worst decision I've ever
made
so did you know when you married me at
sixty one thousand dollars and death I
didn't really know until very close and
it's like so what exactly is the number
because he's just a lovable guy yeah
congratulations and so did that I mean
we're laughing about that but when you
guys sit down and you look at that you
had to have a gulp moment $61,000 you're
looking at it Laura and then Jamie you
got real serious which I guess kind of
had to give you hope Laura it's like
okay at least he's gonna deal with this
crap right right and so I mean was it
was there a lot of stress in the room
that night with that red number at the
bottom I was interesting he's common
agreement we're gonna kill it
I was scared that's for sure because I
thought I'd been living on very little
and been very frugal all throughout this
process leading up to our marriage and
when I thought when we got married I was
like oh we're gonna have so much more
income and is gonna be very comfortable
living when they won't pay off this debt
and they'll be great
and I didn't realize how tight the
margins were until we pulled all those
numbers together and I was I was scared
what about you Jamie you know it was
definitely that the field of fear from
her and even that early you know less
than a month being into married I knew
that if your wife is scared about
something you got to fix it yeah so I go
to them you know try to yeah thank you
try keep my nose down and I'm an
aerospace engineer so I've got a pretty
decent income and I was working a
24-hour rotating shift on getting some
little extra money working from the
overnights and the math comes easy to
you right so when you look at a red
number you go uh-huh
that's less than where I am number
doesn't work yeah we got to fix this and
so you laid into it and so once you just
so both decided and you locked arms the
race is on what was the hardest part
from there
for me it was being patient because I'd
been doing this for seven years and it's
just been such a long haul for me I
never really made much income on my own
and so I was ready I've been ready for
so long to live like no one else and I
was tired of living like no one else not
sure so for me it was patience for me it
was scaling back on the doing stuff in
the here and now yeah
going out with work buddies all the time
you know and just you know let's cut
that back the the little flow money
there's everything you like that that
was because you got married not because
you had a budget not really okay
you know I we have a lot of the same
friends of them especially from our time
at CU and I got you good
very cool so what's your advice to the
youversion from two years ago your wife
is your teammate yeah you gotta trust
her and she'll help you through whatever
cool and I would say that you really
need to make it a priority because
there's so much competition for your
money friends want to go eat out or hey
let's go to the movies there's so much
competition so you have to really
protect I want to be debt-free more than
I want anything else and you almost have
to make it one of your core values that
this is this is number one and so we're
gonna we're gonna be debt-free no matter
what then the magical thing happens you
get on the budget you see where the
numbers are going you you tell them
anywhere to go and then you it it frees
you you know you now have the ability to
save up to go you know visit visit a
friend out of state or you know do what
do whatever you want by sailing to
Nashville and do a debt-free exactly
area so advice advice to engaged couples
from both of your perspectives things
you wish you had done differently during
the engagement well you know we we've
been talking as a couple about a lot of
the important things about stuff that's
important to us for a for a long time
and we did our we did our wedding
pretty cheap our
Laura's parents were able to give us
$10,000 - yeah the whole thing we came
in under budget on the wedding yeah and
so we we actually started giving your
book to some of our engaged friends from
from school yeah so get on the budget
yeah it helps and get on the same page
communication is you wish you had done a
little deeper and had a little more
openness until that last minute cuz you
kind of last minute you discover 61 out
yeah you know I probably especially
because I had my job a little bit ahead
of time could have been a little bit
more deliberate started off a little bit
less but here we are we're not even two
years to be married now and it's worked
out great and it's obviously a very cool
couple I'm just I'm gonna put words in
your mouth I would like for you to have
known it was 61 earlier in the
relationship is that wrong no that's
what I was trying to put words in your
mouth but I'll say it okay that's okay
good very good good for you guys I'm
very proud of you you're Nate couple
you're fun and you obviously are bright
and are working together you got a
really really bright future the things
are gonna be amazing for you guys very
cool
all right Jamie and Lara Boulder
Colorado baby $61,000 paid off in only
18 months making only 80 85,000 they
teamed up and they punched in the face
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
Wow way to go you guys man that was
awesome very well done very well done
all right open phones this hours we talk
about your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five they paid off that at
a rate of $40,000 a year
in 18 months I did sixty one thousand
making eighty eighty-five thousand
dollars a year and so that's how it's
done guys I mean they were on beans and
rice rice and beans they didn't go out
to eat with their friends they didn't
see movies they decided they were
getting out of debt and they're living
on a written game plan that they're both
in agreement to and they killed the debt
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than the damn room
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you